I am Brian Taran I'm the editor of a
website called uh real world data
science and my talk today is to tell you
about how uh we built real world data
science this is a screenshot of it here
how we built that using quto and I guess
some of my journey of uh Discovery and
learning as I move from being um a
journalist who knew pretty much nothing
about uh any of these tools to
somebody who built a website which I'm
quite proud of um and I hope you'll go
and explore it so um I'm a journalist
that means I think a lot about words and
the impact that they can have on people
and how a few words you know strung
together in a short phrase can you know
have a real uh impact on your life make
you think differently about the world
change your perspective whatever it
might be for example will you marry me
right someone says that to you you're
going to feel pretty good about yourself
for a for a while right a few a few
years later maybe things aren't going so
well when you hear those words I want a
divorce and know yeah you know that that
will knock you for six right well I had
a kind of experience like that that
knocked me back a little bit uh recently
when in March
2022 uh my boss came to me and said
build us a website now that isn't quite
as dramatic as will you marry me or I
want a divorce but uh it kind of knocked
me back a little bit because so the
background to this was I had applied for
a job to build a new online publication
for my for my employer um I'd worked as
a print journalist most of my career but
i' i' worked on websites i' done some
design projects uh never built a website
from the ground up but I'd you know i'
been involved in things and you know I
was feeling cocky I knew a bit of HTML I
thought I'd be fine uh how how difficult
can it be to build a website um and then
I started to think about you know all
the steps that I would need to go
through in order to build the website
and uh I felt like I maybe had bit off
more than I could
chew and that but that that all changed
when uh I started speaking to some data
scientist and uh someone said to me do
you know quo right this forword phrase
and it really changed my perspective on
on what what's possible to do with uh
digital Publications now so I'll back up
a little bit and tell you a bit about
the context of where I sort of where I
was coming from so the challenge I work
for uh the Royal statistical Society
we're a membership Organization for
statisticians we've been going for about
200 years um and our president at the
time felt that we needed to do more to
support statisticians uh that are
working as data scientists and also to
contribute more to the the data science
conversation right statisticians have a
role to play in that and we didn't feel
like we were doing uh as much as we
could do so we wanted to create a new
publication uh for data science
professionals something that would focus
on real world examples of of data
science practice and that would
generally kind of support knowledge
sharing within within the
community when I came into the project I
was thinking I wanted to make sure that
the website that we built would be a
suitable home for data scientists to
contribute to because in my previous
role I was editing a magazine uh
statistics magazine called significance
and I spent about eight years really
annoying uh contributors because they
would present these lovingly crafted
latch articles and they'd send them to
me and I'd say excellent thank you very
much could you redo that in word uh and
often that was followed by a deep sigh
so I thought right if we're going to do
this we're going to build something new
we want to build something that uses
tools that data scientists use and that
you know kind of speaking speaking your
language essentially so I started uh
phoning around speaking to people I know
and that's when uh I heard that phrase
do you know quo and the first time I
heard it I just jotted it down in my
notebook I think I misspelled it uh but
it was the second time that this this
came up another person I was speaking to
and somebody else said do you know
quarter and I thought I probably should
look into this so I went across to the
website uh this is what it looks like
sort of now it was broadly the same uh
back when I started looking at it and
this really intrigued me straight away
because you know even with my sort of
very rudimentary knowledge I knew on the
left was like the the raw underlying
code if you like and that was generating
the outputs on the right I like the
outputs on the right I thought they
looked nice and clean and crisp and and
they had a a kind of just a Simplicity
that that I would like in a kind of
online publication I also lik the fact
that the uh I could see that the the
Figures were being generated from the
code I'd spent a lot of the time again
annoying contributors to significance
magazine by telling them that they they
hadn't output in the right resolution or
the right size or whatever it might be
so this could kind of deal with all
those sorts of problems so I thought
great I'm going to learn quto and also
borrow that guy's
shirt uh
so I couldn't I couldn't copy the
hairstyle unfortunately uh so step one
went to the quter website easy right
download I could I've downloaded lots of
things in the past on my PC not a
problem this is where things started to
get difficult for me right I know what a
text editor is I have I recognized our
studio and Jupiter I think I once
accessed a Jupiter notebook uh and
accidentally collapsed all the text
chunks and code cells and I didn't know
what I was doing and got out of there
pretty quick so clearly I needed to
learn more than just quto I need needed
to learn a to as well I picked uh Visual
Studio code because it was first on the
list so two things now learn quto learn
Visual Studio okay fine well anyway
fortunately quto has uh has made this
easy because there's you know a whole
load of tutorials on the site you know
obviously starting with helping me to
get familiar with working with a quto
document and then transitioning over to
looking at how to build a website so I
think maybe it took me several days oh
excuse me several days to a week and I
built my first website a little demo
it's not the world's best uh website but
it was my first website and I felt proud
of it um you could see that you know I'd
started to play around with how we might
position you know different sort of
content blocks and things like that but
there was more work that needed to be
done not least the fact that this was on
my local machine and a website's only
really good if it's actually on the
internet so everybody can see it so I
went back to the quto guide and then I
found this thing about GitHub pages
right so I've been using GitHub mostly
as a f like a kind of personal file
storage I didn't really understand it um
but I was familiar with the word so I
figured GitHub Pages would be the way to
go for this GitHub action this sounded
exciting automatically render your files
didn't want to have to be doing that
manually every time so I thought I would
uh try this but uh I quickly realized
looking at a few GitHub actions I had no
idea what I was doing and I had no idea
what how these things worked so now I
was learning quto learning Visual Studio
code and GitHub as well I have made a
huge mistake I did I really thought that
that was it but I then discovered uh the
section on the quto website which was
the gallery and then this little
subsection here about websites and these
three websites in particular the NASA
and opencape sites uh and min's data
science in a box and along with a quto
website uh these were really helpful to
me because you know as well as looking
at the websites I could go onto the
GitHub repos and look at how the sites
were built I could interrogate the
actions and see see broadly how these
things were working and try and you know
figure it out slowly in my in my head I
mean the actions i' built failed
multiple multiple times uh but
eventually I got somewhere I got
somewhere with it um and you know as I
was digging around in these repos I
realized something that I I guess I
didn't know about GitHub before which is
that it's not just a personal storage
for files right it's a platform for
collaboration and co-creation I'm not a
you know I don't have a software or
engineering background or anything like
that so I never would have had to use it
for that reason
but the fact that I could see in each of
these repos people working together
collaborating on projects uh sharing
ideas solving problems this really
changed my whole perspective about how
we could build our website so I was
thinking about it in a kind of old media
sense before which is we'll build a
website people will come to us and
submit articles and we'll publish them
but I actually thought well maybe we
could actually create this website
together as a community that it isn't
just something that we build and
maintain it's something that every
everybody can feel involved in and can
contribute to I wanted to make sure that
if you you know if you wanted to share
your
expertise but your expertise or your
your passion wasn't necessarily writing
articles about data science projects you
work on maybe you could contribute to
the maintenance of the site maybe you've
uh seen a really cool thing in quto that
you think we should add to our to our
site and you could help us do that maybe
there's something we could you know an
extension or whatever that we could
build and share with a wider
community and when I went back to my
kind of priorities or the the the
challenges that was set for me I kind of
realized that this idea here about sort
creating a support Community around what
we wanted to build was was already in
there it just sort of it took this kind
of process for me to uh I guess for it
to be highlighted to me uh and to draw
it out so you know if you go to the site
now you'll see that you know we we are
uh up and running we have people who who
are contributing to the front end
they're sharing case studies uh they are
putting together Tut tutal and
explainers about data science tools and
methods they're sharing the stories of
their careers and how they got into uh
data science what they've learned uh and
giving advice to people who are uh
looking to follow in their
footsteps and we've also you know
created a a space for people to talk
about the perspectives and and big
themes and challenges in in data
science but the but the other thing that
started to happening and this is and
this has happened organically is that
people have started to think about as I
was saying supporting the website Beyond
just creating content for it so uh about
a month ago now uh a data science
student in the Netherlands Finn Ole hona
got in touch with us and said you know
i' I'd like to build a a template for
real world data science so that if
people want to write for you uh there's
a kind of example quto document in there
which shows all the different code
features that you can use with the
article and when you when they render it
it will look like it will look on your
website and I think that's really
important if you thinking about uh
contributor to a publication thinking
about how you're going to design and set
out your content being able to see what
the finished product is going to look
like is is is key and this and this
really warmed my heart that that s Finn
took the step to do this because it's
something I wanted to do uh but I didn't
have the kind of know how to do it I
knew we needed a template of some sort
but I didn't know how to build it so
Finn stepped up and and helped us to
create it so that's I think you know
showing the the strength of the
community so the these are just a sample
of the people that are that have
contributed to the site so far uh these
are only the contributors who have
GitHub accounts there are people that
kind of contributing through different
different Avenues but you know now we're
starting to see not just people creating
content but people like Finn and Zoe who
I've highlighted who are helping us sort
of work through the Science pop bugs and
all that sort of
stuff I feel like I'm learning a lot
from working uh with this community it's
been it's been really
beneficial um you know one of the things
that I pointed out when I first went to
the to the quto site was that you know
there's this Li rendering of figures
from the document well I we quickly
figured out with some work that this was
going to kill our website rendering
speed so we couldn't use that so the
community helped us to figure out a way
around that uh where we could still
output the figures but uh drop them into
the article as image files instead code
annotation this is a cool new feature
that's in in quto clearly I wasn't
reading the uh updates uh diligently
enough cuz Finn had to point this out to
me that this was a thing right that you
could build it's a really interactive
tactile way for people to kind of
understand what's going on on in your
code and I also learned that designing
for HTML is a lot harder than it first
appeared um to we we we got a design
company to kind of come up with the
brand and the look of the of the website
for us but they literally just dropped a
load of InDesign documents off and said
you go and Implement that now so uh I I
had to figure out CSS pretty quickly and
I and I did that by again going to look
at other people's websites seeing what
they've done and then trying to adapt it
for our own
purposes
and because i' I feel like I've learned
so much from the community I I'm also
trying to sort of give back and and
share what I've learned as basic as it
might be so uh I've been working for a
while now with the American statistical
association's Justice Equity diversity
and inclusion group uh to uh help
support and build uh their website and
that's been really a really good
experience I've been really pleased to
to be involved in that and uh recently
another project came up at the Royal
statistical Society to to develop some
guidance on on data visualization we
were thinking of it as like a kind of
notes for contrib contributors for our
Publications but following the
experience that we had with uh real
world data science and building that we
decided that actually we were going to
take a different approach to it so now
like real world data science it's a
living document essentially uh it's you
know it's built in quto it's has a a uh
um a GitHub repo behind it all the
source files are on there and we're
encouraging people to to contribute uh
and develop that because right data data
visualization changes all the time
standards and best practices evolve and
we want this document to be a document
that
evolves
so this is where I am today I rather I
guess bullishly described my talk as
from journalist to coder I don't think I
should say I'm a coder I've done some
coding um but I wish I'd learn coding at
school I think my my career might have
gone in a bit of a different direction
uh I I I I really do enjoy the technical
side of the job and spend far too much
time on it uh fortunately my boss isn't
here to to hear that um but you know for
people like me for journalists and
others who don't have a coding
background I I I kind of the message I
wanted to to to get across really is
that you know if I can learn it through
quone experimenting uh with with this
platform that anyone can
really and also the discovery about open
source collaborative publication has
been has been a really good one for me
because I again am a journalist old
media by by training you're kind of talk
to you know it be quite insulate you
only work in small teams or individually
you keep things underw wrapped you don't
share it with people until you're ready
to publish because you don't want anyone
to gazump you and uh steal your story
before you publish it but actually I
think there's a lot of benefit and
Advantage for being public and open
about what it is that you're doing and
inviting people in to to contribute to
that and so this is where we are today
as a website so we went from this to
this um and please do check out the site
and and see how it's changed this this
was where it was last week we published
50 articles so far uh we've got the 19
GitHub contributors and many more to
come hopefully uh 12,000 users and
40,000 views since we
launched so March 2022 build us a
website that's what my boss said to me
and I can now say I built a website and
I'm very pleased about that but I think
it'd probably be more accurate to say
that we as in the community of people
behind real world data science are
building a website and it continues to
develop and if I had to leave you with a
short phrase of my own to think about it
would be why not join us so thank you
very much here are our details thanks
for
[Music]
listening thank you so much thank you we
do have some questions on slid if you
want to put your own there please do the
keyword is
um Grand Hall I is that correct
um so the first one is Brian uh what is
what is your solution for hosting and
deploying your quarter website hosting
and deploying oh so we use GitHub Pages
basically that's how that's how we use
it I know that there is there's a danger
that the bigger the site gets because
there starts being caps on the amount of
traffic you can have going to the site
but we'll cross that bridge when we come
to it we're in very familiar territory
for us here with good her
PES
um could the website template be used
for offline deliverables as well so that
the brand matches between the two
uh yeah yeah you can do that so you can
it can render out to I I guess uh oh no
actually won't no it won't The Styling
won't carry across but it just be in
HTML The Styling but you can you you can
use the template to Output to word docs
but it won't the the theme and stuff
like that won't carry across we should
make that happen sorry we should make
that happen well it' be quite nice to do
that yeah but I was I was inspired by
M's talk about all the things that you
can do in terms of Journal templates and
things like that so yeah I have to look
into that and research in more
depth
okay um what
else oh what is your next quarto project
going to be my next quarto project uh
well I am slowly building my own
personal website but that was really I
only kind of set that up as a place
where I could break things without
worrying about the actual website
falling over but at some point I would
like to finish that and maybe start like
blogging and doing things writing about
my interests like video games and movies
and stuff like that
so so basically you got
everybody gets a work christas yeah I
think it as I say it's I'm I kind of
become a bit of a advocate for it now
and I think any project that we're going
to do in the Royal statistical society
that involves and a publication of some
point like an online publication at some
point I think we're going to make sure
it's rooted in uh quto and in uh in that
kind of Open Source collaborative space
a lot of things can change in 200 years
the Royal statistical Society is present
time um what else oh yes how are you
handling multiple contributors meaning
do you have different rights levels or
permission levels for your contributors
uh so at the moment the uh we don't have
multiple people contributing directly to
the GitHub repo so what that it tends to
work is that people might build an
article in their own repository and then
they'll share the files with us over
time yeah we would look to to do that as
people become more familiar with it but
actually it's most of the people we've
we've worked with so far haven't kind of
gone all in in uh using GitHub in the
way we would like them to as in being
the the source of creating the files
submitting the article editing reviewing
and all that sort of stuff but that's
kind of where we want to get to that's
our that's our vision
anyway okay um the next one is sort of
like but really type question um how
long did it take you to get the first
version online and I'm going to add to
this question how long did it take you
for your personal homepage from why one
for for like the r the real world data
science homepage and the other one for
your personal one like try one and try
two oh okay uh it took quite a took
quite a long time getting it up and
running I have to say um I don't know I
don't I didn't keep count but I think my
uh email inbox there's a folder
somewhere of all the failed runs of the
GitHub action and and I I was wondering
why is this why is it not displaying yet
and then I went in there there was like
I don't know 100 failed attempts uh so
yeah it pretty it was pretty sad I still
have problems with GitHub actions now
we're trying to figure out on this data
visualization guidance site somewhere
where there's a thing we want to do with
it but we just can't get the GitHub
actions to work and there are people
more knowledgeable than me who can't
figure out so this is your called action
for the community help him TR to get ACC
save me yeah yeah especially since you
did not go into the direction and tell
me yeah second TR is to easy so um but
yes please help him troubleshoot his get
up actions we all need that help from
time to time thank you so much for the
great presentation thanks for listening
thank
[Applause]
you